hello i'm adam brody i'm here with
buzzfeed to take the test
which character from the oh the awk
the oc the oc which character from the
oc are you
first things first pick an oc parent
sandy colin kristen cohen jimmy cooper
julie cooper veronica townsend
caleb nickel i'm a mama's boy christian
cullen
which post oc roll of adam brodius is
your fave nikolai wolfe from jennifer's
body
tim from life partners i worked with my
wife on that so that's high for me
daniel the domes from ready or not
freddy freeman from shazam carter webb
from in the land of women
abe applebaum from the kid detective
well one of my favorite roles ever
i love this movie to pieces let's go kid
detective select an iconic lyric
we've been on the run driving in the sun
looking out for number one driving down
to 101
right back where we started from
right back where we started from i don't
know i like them all i can't choose but
i picked that one she's a famous oc
guest star
paul wesley is donnie olivia wilde is
alex kelly
max greenfield as young sandy cohen
nikki reed as sadie campbell chris pratt
is
shay cook shailene woodley is baby
caitlyn cooper
you know what i like all these people a
lot but um dude i see the most stills
paul wesley that's my pal
pretend it's the 2000s which team drama
are you watching after the oc
gossip girl one tree hill veronica mars
laguna beach dawson's creek gilmore
girls
ooh i gotta go personal steak and that's
gossip girl
or gilmore girls let's throw it over to
my wife
which memorable oc moment hits you right
in the feels when
ryan called sandy dad for the first time
when summer and seth shared their
spider-man kiss
when marissa had her poolside meltdown
when sandy taught marissa how to smear a
bagel when the squad gets stuck in the
mall
overnight when seth introduced ryan and
the world
to chris mca boy well i guess i could do
the spider-man
kiss or the christmaca that seems a
really you know what i'm going to go
chris mccook because that seems to make
a lot of people
happy that gave you know that helped
popularize the holiday finally pick
a beach view from your pool house a
calming palm tree
a sailboat at sunset a picturesque pier
a scenic escape
a cozy hammock a lovely lighthouse this
is random but uh
don't ask me why there's been a lot of
lighthouse talk uh at my house lately
i got seth cohen rainy champ a quick
comeback obscure pop culture references
and made up holidays you're everyone's
favorite funny guy but beneath the woody
exterior is a caring dude who will do
anything for his friends and
family good that could have been awkward
i mean it makes sense
the quiz says i'm seth and i'm i'm going
to trust the ai
probably knows me better than i know
myself thanks buzzfeed everyone if you
can
kid detective in theaters possibly by
you
depending on where you live and also
don't forget to vote
you